[Music]
first to Turkey air where tens of
thousands of supporters of a present
receipt erdogan have been rallying in
Istanbul a week before elections erdogan
is facing his toughest challenge since
taking power two decades ago several
opinion polls show him trailing
opposition leader Kemal kilish deloro
attended the rally in Istanbul
in the greatest
political history in the last three
decades
[Music]
right now just announced that 1.7
million Turkish people have attended
this rally the roads are jammed and the
Subways are jammed and there have been
tight security measures and presents are
done yesterday described the May 14
election as an election of survival
today he is mostly focusing on the
achievements that turkey has gone
through during the ruling up parties
Administration is focusing on the big
investment project that his government
has concluded and basically is focusing
on the Milestone industry projects
including the first electrical car the
drones the defense industry and
everything and he has been accusing the
opposition of a lying with the outdoor
Workers Party the pkk however this is
and who suggests that everything is
mechanic and this is probably the most
difficult political test for president
erdogan in the last three decades